everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're continuing our
coverage of the 2018 World Chess
Championships in London between the
champion Magnus Carlsen from Norway
against the American at Fabiano Caruana
in game number one yesterday we did see
the players play a marathon seven hours
a hundred and fifteen moves and they did
draw that game Fabiano really even
though playing the white pieces was on
the defence most of the game Magnus
trying to find a way to take his small
advantage turn it into a victory he was
not able to but I thought like he'd be
pretty happy with the draw with the
black pieces so today we have game
number two we have flipped sides Magnus
Carlsen playing the white pieces Fabiano
playing the black pieces time control so
everyone is aware if you didn't watch
the first video hundred minutes for the
first 40 moves every time you make a
move you do get 30 seconds added once
you've done those 40 moves you get
additional 50 minutes after the next 20
moves you get 15 extra minutes that's
all the time that you have but you do
get that extra 30 seconds each move so
we'll go ahead and get into it Magnus
Carlsen starts with pawn to d4 and that
f6 Knight f3 and then pawn d5 now Magnus
Carlsen loves to start with pawn to e4
but we do know that Fabiano is a really
good player when it comes to the Petrov
defence soap on e5 Knight f3 knight c6
my guess is my English Carlsen just
doesn't want to have to deal with that
right now has a lot of preparation
coming into this tournament he feels
pretty confident with playing pawn to d4
so after Knight f3 and pawn d5 we see
pawns c4 with this as the Queen's Gambit
here Fabiana decides to decline that
pawn to e6 93 Bishop e7 Bishop to f4 so
Magnus Carlsen doesn't go down the main
lines from here we're used to seeing
pawn g3 think head o on to the Kings
side of the board or maybe Queen to b3
just solidifying this light square
diagonal here or you could see just pawn
takes on d5 another
fine possibility even Bishop to g5 if
you want to get the bishop you do want
to get outside the pawn chain before
pawn to e3 Bishop to f4 completely fine
just not as common as some of the other
moves castle on the kingside pawn to e3
pawn c5 and then the pawns do take here
Bishop takes on c5 so controlling the
dark squares in the center of the board
Queen c2 just continuing development
here knight c6 development as well pawn
a3 recognizing that the knight could
easily come down to before put a lot of
pressure on White's wants to make sure
that he stops that right there Queen
down to a5 pinning down this Knight to
the King this that's not gonna move too
much does have to be aware that if the
pawn were to come down here he does need
to make sure he keeps this pawn here on
e3 to stop this doesn't want to have to
force his knight to move because it
can't right now being pinned down he
would lose that material so this is
something to think about for Magnus
Carlsen he plays rook to d1 and now this
is where things get interesting
Fabiano plays the move rook to d8 now if
you look at it and look that crazy just
moving the rook over here he's already
castled not going to really do much with
his bishop more than likely he's gonna
be playing something pawn to b6 Bishop
here to b7 at some point get that
involved Bishop here to d7 not the move
he's looking to do but Magnus Carlsen
was perplexed after this move he had
Spence not more than 15 seconds on his
other moves every now they may take 30
seconds but just blazing through his
moves and took 17 minutes on this
particular position even from his own
Twitter that the play Magnus Carlsen
said that this move really had him
confused was not prepared for it he had
never played against this variation in
the opening and as he studied Magnus
Carlsen after the game said he just was
not prepared for this at all hadn't seen
any games where this even it came up he
had seen Bishop coming back here to e7
as one option has also seen rook
eight he did not think that rook to d8
was even a natural move so he said after
the game he was gonna go look over this
with his team and see why would Fabiano
even come up with this is this a new
novel move that that's this is a new
theory that people may think about or
was this something that you know
probably wasn't the best move he's just
trying to catch magnus carlsen off-guard
that's exactly what it did though and
magnus carlsen plays a Bishop to e2 even
before this a couple moves of four if we
look at the rook to d1 he was even
thinking about the bishop here - E - so
after 17 minutes and rook to d8 he
decides to play Bishop to e2 didn't take
very long for Fabiano to play Knight to
e4 and then another 10 plus minutes go
off the board before we see castle on
the King side so very similar to
yesterday as Fabiano seemed to be caught
off guard spent about 30 minutes on two
moves we see the same thing for magnus
carlsen 12 moves in and he's already
more than 30 minutes behind his opponent
when it just comes to time control
Fabiana decides to take the knight on c3
the pawn recaptures and this is a trap
that Fabiano needs to make sure that he
avoids he rightfully exchanges gives his
opponent double pawns here on the C file
but he needs to make sure he does not
take this pond right here on a3 it looks
like it's a free pawn but unfortunately
it's not so he does play pawn to h6 now
if you look at it there's two different
ways that black could capture the worst
one would be Queen take on a3 because
we're over here - a1 the queen is going
to fall Fabiano's not going to do that
now even the bishop that's not as bad
the Queen's not gonna fall but it's
still very bad work over here - a1 can't
really move the bishop wants to come
back here it's gonna fall to the pawn
Queen Falls as well if the Queen moves
then the bishop is just going to fall
for free maybe pawn to e5 attacking the
bishop Knight takes Knight recaptures
Bishop up here pawn takes on a c4 Bishop
comes back to g3 Bishop over here to
east
maybe queen a two now starting to attack
those pieces that we talked about queen
c3 queen takes on a three we do see an
exchange right here rook can come down
but at the end of the day this is gonna
be a fine position for white does have
the advantage of two minor pieces they
also happen to be the bishop pair so at
the end of the day Fabiano's not going
to fall for this especially since he's
the one they initiated the Knight to c3
he definitely had to have calculated and
he rightfully plays pawn to h6 making
sure that his opponent now can't play
anything Knight to g5 Bishop here to g5
as well so nice transition for Fabiano
now pawn to a five man who's recognizing
that before he had the pawn on a three
this was protecting and controlling the
square on b4 after the exchange his pawn
on c3 is doing that for him so decides
to push up with his pawn on a fort
Knight comes back here to e7 Knight to
e5 and then Bishop to d6 now afterwards
Magnus Carlsen said that this was a
mistake should not have played Knight to
e5 it was a miscalculation did not
notice that he could have played Bishop
to d6 now if he wasn't looking at this a
couple other options maybe was looking
at just rook to b1 now Bishop to d6 is
fine
but in the game decided to play Knight
to e5 and then Bishop to d6 and then C
takes on d5 you know if if Bishop didn't
come to d6 you could have seen Knight to
c6 and then from here pawn takes pawn
takes pawn up here c4 you could see an
exchange in the center of the board so
this is another variation magnus carlsen
could have been looking at but Bishop d6
we do see the pawns come off the board
and now we see the knight come down take
on d5 and the Queen and the knight are
both eyeing this pawn on c3 so the
backward pawn White has to worry about
because there's two attackers right now
first thing we see is the bishop come to
f3 this is the position where Magnus
Carlsen had an opportunity
place something very different my guess
is if he had more time he would have
played the move Knight takes on f7 they
asked him specifically about this
position said did you consider this he
said absolutely I just didn't find
anything that made sense my take on that
was he just didn't have enough time he's
about 45 minutes behind his opponent
when it comes to time controls it's
gonna take him another 15 20 minutes
really analyze all the nuances of this
position he just doesn't have that time
right now so he didn't play this but we
can go ahead and analyze it ourselves as
I'm sure he will be doing with his team
later on after the match but the King
takes here on f7 Bishop takes d6 rook
takes d6 Bishop up here to h5 and this
starts to put pressure on Fabiano as far
as how he defends this correctly even if
Fabiano chooses correctly I still think
it could allow Magnus Carlsen to get
some time back because it's not easy
there's a lot of ways that Fabiano could
fall into a very very bad position some
of the easiest ways for Magnus Carlsen
and women will be just a blunder but
that would be things like pawn to g6
main thing to notice is the Queen on c2
is very very much involved into the game
now Queen takes g6 this is gonna end in
a mate King to e7 it's gonna chase the
King down eventually there will be a
checkmate here depending on where black
moves doesn't have a ton of options if
we come back and say instead of pawn to
g6 maybe King to f8 okay still going to
be in May it's gonna be very similar to
as we just saw in the previous example
this is now threatening King to f7 how
does black stop that comes to be 7 but
from here same position it's going to
chase the King down it is going to be
mate now if he decides to instead go
back from the 8th rank and immediately
play King to e7 it's not going to be
mate but still not going to be good
Queen to g6 getting that queen of all
them to the game Bishop to d7 taking the
pawn here on at g7 starting to force the
King back and then all of a sudden pawn
to c4 this is a huge
threats you can see if the knight moves
this rook is going to fall right here
probably the best move after Bishop to
h5 is going to be King to g8 but white
still has a good game after this pawn to
e4 forcing the Knights move Knight comes
back over here to f4 now is attacking
the bishop here on h5 White has to worry
about that but can take the rook here
first on d6 Queen takes rook up here d8
check after the King moves this is gonna
be a fine position it still has a lot of
opportunity for white to attack here my
guess is he would got some time back as
far as the time controls disparity we
would get much closer if Fabiano's
trying to think about all this but in
the game itself we did not see Knight
takes on f7 I wish we would have just
would have been fun to see in the game
we did get Bishop to f3 now the knight
takes on f4 this is probably better than
the Queen taking here on c3 then the
Queen takes Knight takes here now that I
can come up to f7 a little little tricky
for black here after the King takes then
we see the same example as before but we
do have White's going into the endgame
with the bishop pair we don't have a
very active rook from black the knight
over here on a4 is not very active as
well so although black is up in material
I think wine wood white would be fine
here so that's why we do see Fabiano
play Knight takes over here on f4 we see
the pawn capture Bishop takes on e5 and
then the rook to d8 Queen takes now the
pawn takes on e5 Queen down to c7
rook over here to b1 the rook and the
bishop are now eyeing at this pawn here
on b7 Black has a couple options he
could decide to just not worry about
that start to gobble up material on the
center of the board decides to instead
play rook to b8 now Queen to d3 Bishop
d7 a 5 and then Bishop c6 and if you're
watching the commentary listen to a lot
of the grandmasters they said this is a
tough position for Magnus Carlsen
because while it is very
roll ish there's still a lot of
opportunity for magnus carlsen to falter
in this spot and lose the game it really
comes down to can Fabiano find the win
here or is magnus carlsen going to be
able to get the draw very similar to we
saw in Game one
the player on the white side is the one
just trying to get a draw Magnus Carlsen
from here plays Queen to d6 trying to
simplify the game much like we saw Fabi
on doing game number one when he moved
his Queen over here to f7 checking his
opponents King trading off the Queens
now we see Queen come up here to d6 we
exchanged on the board this does get us
to overdraw position double pawns on the
F file definitely going into the endgame
not as good for Magnus Carlsen but this
is a theoretical drawing game we do see
as you know you would imagine one we're
not at 30 moves yet so they can't draw
but just trying to see if Fabiano can
push for a victory pawn here to a6 pawn
can't take rook would just take up here
on b8 so pawn to b6 upon up here c5 same
thing pawn can't take the rook would
take the other rook King to a d7 pawn
takes pawn takes right here just really
forcing some moves knowing that the rook
has to come over here to a8 rook takes
on b6 rook takes on a7 both sides have
four pawns but this pawn right here is
not long for the world King to g2 pawn
to e5 rook down here to b4 then upon f5
pushing on the Kings side the board
could have taken this pawn here on d6
but recognizing that he is gonna get it
sooner than later anyway rook to b6
King down here to e6 then upon d7 King
takes you can see Fabiano does have the
advantage here but it's not real clear
how he's going to turn this into a
victory they don't play too many more
moves from here and then after moves 47
they did decide to draw this is one of
the things that I
which did not happen excuse me they did
do a few moves later than this to move
49
I wish Fabiana would have tried to
continue in the game I do recognize that
the grandmasters watching this giving
their comments here we're saying that
this is a drawn game but it was a drawn
game in game number one 60 moves before
they ended
Fabiano at the end of that was exhausted
felt like it was torture to try to
defend that I felt like he could have
given Magnus Crossan a piece of his own
medicine and made him play this out for
another 40 50 moves there's no way that
Fabiana was going to lose this game it's
gonna be a draw war Magnus Carlsen makes
a mistake he could squeak out a victory
here but that's not what happened after
49 moves we do see the players draw so
we are gonna have a rest day tomorrow
had some exciting chess so far but we'll
be excited to see what happens after
they spend some time with their teams
figure out how their preparation is
working hopefully we see some some new
interesting lines coming out after that
but thanks everyone for watching the
commentary on at game number 2 we will
have analysis of every single game at
nights I'll be making the videos after I
go through watch the game listen all the
other commentaries as I'm watching it
live and then just going through adding
my own analysis so thank you guys so
much for tuning in and I'll see you in
game number 3